natura mierda
la mia età
ah ah ah ah dittatura mierda
[Musica]
dittatura
certo
[Musica]
ma era summit ad ora
mamma
certo venga merda merda merda
dittatura di altri
va bene tutto aperta
niente merda merda di quella merda
ah ah ah be for men
venier da pendant con eva
paolo ragazzi comunque più difficili
contro pensassi dittatura mierda parte è
una cosa parecchio incasinata perché
comunque allo scoperto in questi primi
minuti di gioco ben articolati da un
commentare i super super intenso ho
scoperto che per recuperare vita bisogna
fare così aspetta a [ __ ] non riesco
più a per recuperare vita io devo fare
le esecuzioni pubbliche così certo una
volta sono riuscito basta a partire da
buttana chi è stato a tre fate tutti
quanti teste di culo o faccio così o non
recupero vita poi la barra della mia
vita e non la vedo mancana con la
software madre la madre sua madre bene
anche questo tipo di commentare è molto
articolato 1 ragazzo karate kid karate
kid è la madonna lo faccio saltare in
aria
dettatura merda a ea un dato che storia
quindi adesso devo aspettare la prossima
onda porca [ __ ] un casino dando a gaza
arrivano da dove eccoli eccoli
merda multi kill boe la madonna guardia
stragi non avevo visto ragazzi clark a
[ __ ] non avevo visto che erano segnati
sulla mappa il che rende tutto molto più
semplice
ok è chiuso nel ciclismo è la madonna
quanto violento sto gioco vita della mia
eta beta
e vabbè ma [ __ ] quanta gente che
cazzo c'è un lanciafiamme da qualche
parte vi prego prima di cominciare a
ragazzi musica a tema
[Musica]
anyway belli ragazzi miei io sto gioco
perfetto stavo per dire io sto gioco non
ci sono giocare perchè in teoria
dovresti anche difenderti invece io
sparo con un disperato response
pure sposare ma io voglio voglio i colpi
di lanciafiamme dov'è il mio
lanciafiamme
poi la cosa bella è che se ne accorgono
e subito con lanciafiamme ovviamente
quanto bello vote for trump che ti
brucia tutti morti veramente quanta
cattiveria
quanta cattiveria ed io non volevo giuro
aia mi fanno male le folle proiettili
potete non spararmi addosso mi dà
fastidio grazie l'unico gioco nella vita
in cui per recuperare vita devi fare
esecuzioni pubbliche cioè bova verano
parole è la cosa più trash della storia
c'è veramente cazzo protesti deficiente
e vabbè che disastro che ha su vari
chiesto due trevor e michael di gta in
confronto sono i teletubbies a ragazzi
miei oggi l'afa vj enterprise vi
presenta il nuovo termosifone portatile
avete freddo e voilà torna la
temperatura corporea in due secondi aia
non è spenta
sono morto perché non sono riuscito a
entrare in una porta veneti contro il
disagio in questo momento d'accordo
ragazzi allora direi di provare l'ultima
cosa facciamo power plant l'ultimo
livello come io metto ha comunque messo
difficile modalità e cioè ma non ho
fatto proprio da [ __ ] e infatti non
riescono è la madonna veramente
porca [ __ ]
aiuto ai la macchina
pietra e grazie non c'è quello che mi
apre lo sportello dove el accoglienza
salve lei è velato ma tanto è difficile
sto gioco in realtà si è giocato bene il
suo gioco impossibile ci ha veramente
incasinatissimo è queste difficoltà hard
c'è ancora difficoltà extreme bonifico
text link succede a mettere anche piede
dentro la mappa c'è morì subito perché a
[ __ ] quasi mi stanno sparando
esigo a ritagliare era affanculo crepate
to corrono nelle foreste
preferisco lo slider me home e le
persone possa fare curiosità non voglio
provare un attimo una cosa in sé in cioè
l'utile prima è la difficoltà hard
quindi due difficoltà in meno vediamo a
livello insein che cosa succedeva per
curiosità ai ragazzi solo per capire
secondo me non carica è non sono ancora
morto che strano
ok
merda
è facile facile raccontando anche il
fatto che ce n'erano altri 6 milioni va
bè ragazzi questa è la dittatura merda
non è vero si chiama 63 di questo gioco
lo dico alla fine perché sono uno
youtuber professionista con quello che
l'episodio e spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto cose da ragazzini e video
piaciuto il suo commento è un mi piace
anche a pagine di facebook come negli 80
notiziari che cosa che siete lì ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella che
vorrei chiudere con una pistola tipo non
mi viene il termine asili dittatura
merda però non ce l'ho quindi mi
accontento del telecomando che l'arma la
distruzione più grossa dell'ultimo
secolo dai ragazzi